bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro bové de
lecture nathalie wolf on est avec vous
êtes en pays conquis vente avec des
étudiants des autres visions d'olive est
ce qu est ce qu on va parler du prix du
roman étudiants qui est un formidable
prix qui essayent de nouveau puisque
c'était la 9e édition
avec caroline chardère bonjour et avec
lilian le marchand vous êtes tous les
deux étudiants en master recherche et
création littéraire à l'université de
versailles saint quentin et jurés du
prix du roman étudiants un
peut-être peut-être nous raconter
comment c'est arrivé ce prix du roman et
étudiants dans votre cursus
universitaire
et bah c'est tout simplement en semestre
un an on suit un séminaire de madame
bombardier n'a hélas en concurrence avec
madame bombard on suit un séminaire qui
s'appelle justement de critiquer
création et mena mon verre a tout fait
pour qu'on participe à ce à ce prix du
roman des étudiants donc
et donc si pour nous ça a été
obligatoire ce fut une très bonne
expérience
voilà peut-être avant de parler du prix
puisque vous nous avez vous avez évoqué
ce master moi qui enseigne avait dans
une autre formation dont je ne connais
rien à votre espace littéraire est-ce
que vous pouvez nous raconter un petit
peu ce qu'on y fait dans ce masters
recherche la crasse et original je crois
que c'est tout récent d'ailleurs comme
création masters alors comment est ce
qu'on fait dans ce n'est pas parce qu'on
apprend
l'écriture déjà en partie c'est un
cursus qui est vraiment qui est
ambivalent una des séminaires de
recherche et on a des cours magistraux
sur la littérature sur la littérature ça
va te la du xviie siècle au 21ème siècle
du coup donc la littérature toute
récente et à côté on a aussi des
ateliers d'écriture avec des professeurs
ou des écrivains non mesdames oui et
puis liés l'écriture et la recherche en
fin de compte ne sont pas en fait deux
choses de séparer en écrivant ça nous
aide pour la recherche sur nos sujets de
recherche et en en faisant aussi de la
recherche et nous aident voilà alors
tous n'ont pas forcément envie d'écrire
mais parmi nous qui avons envie d'écrire
ça nous donne des idées
voilà on est conscient que quand on
écrit il y a tout un passé il ya tout un
héritage et vous avez envie quand est-ce
que d'écrire vous avez envie d'être
décrire d'en faire votre profession ou
en tout cas de deux écrivains
c'est une idée
c'est bien c'est mon mieux homme
qui mène aussi à d'autres carrières que
l'écriture et à l'enseignement et bien
sûr tout l'équipement
littéraire met d'ailleurs elle
reviendrait aussi pour vous par une
livre de temps en temps avec plaisir
est-ce que alors on va parler évidemment
des dessins court roman qui étaient des
romans du qui était sélectionnée dans ce
prix du roman étudiants mais est ce
qu'il ya des auteurs comme ça qui vous
qui sont pour vous des auteurs qui vous
inspire
vous parlez des auteurs d'aujourd'hui
d'aujourd'hui ou d'hier peu importe
les quais sont désactivés qu'ils
utilisent et romancier préféré si vous
voulez
moi j'aime beaucoup sylvain tesson oui
tamang le voyage j'aime beaucoup le
voyage donc sylvain tesson intérêts
comme ça en sibérie seul
déjà
adoré j'aime beaucoup sarah marquis
après il ya aussi de la littérature
des états unis que j'apprécie par
exemple richard powers avec l'arbre
monde donc c'est un peu d'aidé roman
engagé oui là
dedans voilà dans l'écologie et dans les
questions planétaires et leur demander
est-ce que le roman a justement été une
façon de ba d'intervenir sur le marché
des sociétés
plus qu'avec un et cesc roman là mais
cette fois il a remis les terrasses
tueur la création permet parfois de voir
les réalités mieux je pense moi que les
que les essais eux mêmes ou que les
intellectuels presque je suis d'un oui
mais c'est pas pour rien que depuis
longtemps on dit
la représentation tout ça oui oui mais
oui et puis un plaire et instruire enfin
vraiment s'est pas séparé sans et je
pense que c'est toujours d'actualité
bien sûr et contrairement aux essais les
romands ils sont un peu moins froid
peut-être je dis pas que les seuils sont
écrits mais cette différence écrit de
manière à ce que ça a commencé par un
roman voilà je trouve donc voilà bah
j'espère que vous allez publier bientôt
mais c'est bien simple c'est bien de
dettes dans ses ateliers on en parle un
peu du prix alors c'est comme ça que
romo qui sont sélectionnés au départ
et donc il ya des votes dans toute la
france oui mais ça va il n'y a pas que
le sqv seulement les étudiants restent
donc ça fait des centaines d'espèces des
milliers d'étudiants qui votent pour ce
prix ce qui est ce qui donc absolument
remarquable et c'est tout pas dit pardon
c'est un prix france culture télérama
reims tout à fait et c'est la neuvième
édition en diminution alors comment ce
prix fonctionne t-il raconté mon un
petit peu alors vous avez des livres
le broker est non alors déjà pour
participer on va déposer un dossier de
candidature avec une petite avec le
critique une petite critique d'une
centaine de mots il me semble s'arrêter
mais sur un roman qu'on choisit enfin
sur un livre qu'on choisit nous-mêmes et
après nous on a reçu par contre les les
livres en format pdf les a pas reçus au
format la gare à pied mais notre
professeur du coup mathilde lombard qui
supervisait le séminaire avait avait des
exemplaires papier qui puisqu'elle
pouvait nous fournir à chaque fois si on
avait envie de les lire en papier pas et
pas sur un ordinateur ou dix autres sont
d'accord alors bon peut-être on peut
rentrer dans le vif du sujet
commencer par le vainqueur on le garde
pour la fin garde pour la garde des
sceaux préféré
aller jusqu'à promettre quoi pas bien
sûr le le prix a été attribué lundi
anticipant la sueur dit oui lundi matin
13 décembre voilà donc donc voilà c'est
pas c'est pas un scoop non plus
mais peut-être que les gens qui nous
regardent ne savent pas encore de quoi
enfin un suspense et on pourrait
peut-être commencer donc par un dlc donc
d'annoncer qu'il n'est pas nouvelle
puisque grosse pomme explique montcalm
de l'oreille pour la croix je suis un
peu un peu nul dans le match et on
pourrait commencer par le temps qui
viennent ça vous va oui bien sûr la
fille qu'on appelle qui est chez le ch
et d'éditeurs traditionnel tanguy viel
qui est discussions des éditions de
minuit où il va en parler
mais qu'importe on peut déjà dire de
quoi oui sans besoin de partir devant et
de deux viols au produit weepu et
affirmant tout à fait non c'est une
histoire très très actuelle au vent
inquiets qui résonne beaucoup dans
l'actualité oui oui c'est un lien avec
avec l'actuel l'actualité et c'est alors
tout simplement c'est l'histoire de max
le corps qui est boxeur mais qui aussi
chauffeur pour le maire de la ville et
max le corps à une fille qui s'appelle
laura est là vingt ans à peu près elle
est donc toute jeune mais elle est aussi
très belle et
suite à la 2s que son père lui a poussé
un peu
elle a suscité le maire pour avoir un
logement parce qu'en général ça prend
beaucoup de temps et du coup c'est
elle était en relation du coup avec avec
le maire donc voilà à partir de là ils
étaient là ils me posent devant la
totalité tout à fait il a vu le son de
son statut
de mère est quelqu'un de puissant il a
des relations
donc voilà une face à lui il y à une
jeune fille qui qui est très jeune et
qui d'un autre côté aussi ne constitue
pas là ça en rend compte quand enfin le
voit pardon quand elle est
face aux policiers pour déposer plainte
ce n'est pas non plus aussi la victime
idéale c'est vrai il a posé nue et c'est
bien dommage servir nouvelle série a le
maire agresseurs réalité pour fournir
ces témoignages
mais on est en développement dans une
actualité comme forte parce que c'est le
vrai passé de combat face aux puissants
quand même bien sûr
alors dans ce livre quelles sont les
qualités de ce livre je trouve que le
personnage de laura est très très bien
fait dans tous les cas il est vraiment
très très bien fait parce qu'il
représente vraiment la jeunesse entre
guillemets mais surtout la naïveté
oui la naïveté et il représente aussi
vraiment bien
cette la dynamique entre quand on est
avec quelqu'un qui a plus de pouvoir que
nous et qu'on en est conscient et voilà
après l'écriture aussi de tanguy viel
est quand même très particulière à les
particuliers même
je l'aimais vraiment beaucoup et on a lu
du coup un autre livre un autre livre de
tanguy viel pour un autre séminaire et
c'était insoupçonnable publié aux
éditions menu aussi et
et bien sûr sans fin j'ai reconnu tout
du moins son écriture dans les deux et
je trouve qu'elle est vraiment très très
jolie oui à la sacristie on va passer
peut-être aux livres
non non je prends des choses un petit
peu des extraits parce que c'est vrai
que c'est un test c'est un style quoi
après oppose me wade a adhéré ça peut
perturber parfois aussi mais c'est un
vrai style tanguy viel
tout le temps qui viennent
voilà c'est donc ça s'appelle la fille
qu'on appelle de tanguy viel et c'est
aux éditions de minuit
est-ce qu'on passe à un roman qu'est
m'en parlait beaucoup de feux de bien de
commencer je le trouve formidable
dans son début mais je sais sur
l'adultère 70 adultes est tout à fait
libre qui veulent évoquer oui à les
lions alors on prend ce but on se fie
deux personnages de personnages
différents suis d'abord lors une mère de
famille professeur en université et
clément qui lui travaille dans une
banque juste plus exactement quelles
sont
travaille dans la finance à la banquise
a way par la banque qui sait le monde sa
banque on n'a pas le nom officiel
oui voilà exactement ils se rencontrent
pour un séminaire de base pour pour
lors et
après il ya une histoire d'amour où
c'est toute la question oui c'est toute
la question que l'on se pose en tout cas
on a l'impression que c'est une histoire
d'amour mais en même temps on se demande
un peu ce que c'est parce que les deux
personnages eux mêmes
se demande s'ils sont amoureux l'un de
l'autre et s'ils sont si la relation va
vraiment quelque part sachant que donc
leurs et l'or est marié et a donc de
deux enfants oui 2,6 et voilà ensuite
donc leur suit l'évolution de la
relation jusqu'à vendredi
sur le désir sur l'amour sur le quai
qu'est ce que l'amour au fond c'est ça
qu'est ce que le désir qu'est ce que est
ce qu'on peut dire c'est bien justement
cela je me suis demandé comment ça c'est
de partager
parce qu'il nous semble du moins que
c'est plutôt l'ennui profond
utilise à rapprocher
et pas forcément et pas forcément
l'amour voilà après ce n'est que notre
avis maria pro chez vous l'avez
rencontré bien faire malgré les modèles
cavale elle est venue signer son livre
exactement et elle défend maintenant
c'est vraiment histoire d'amour
ce qui est assez curieux enfin parce que
le puits madame bovary
il ya eu
c'est beaucoup plus commun que que du
temps de flaubert
et là c'est sûr y'a juste parce que
les titres des chapitres assez
particulier oui en fait on suit les
chapitres
sage vers 14h en dc 37 bfr 15 tirs et
mines fc 80 minutes tu es à 15 ça veut
dire quoi enfin c'est expliqué au début
du livre ça c'est les chapitres de sur
clément en fait
ccj plus le mot mais en gros ses signes
vitaux donc c'est à dire ça la fréquence
cardiaque l'attend est
exactement pareil dans la finance il est
hyper connecté il a tout ce qu'il faut
aujourd'hui
il ya littéralement des références à la
pandémie dans tout bien sûr aussi plus
donc c'est vraiment ancré à dieu me
voilà donc feu de mariée pour chez séché
c'est chez fayard et on continue
peut-être avec mahmoud de la montée des
eaux oui ça vous voir vous
c'est parce que je ne serais ce que le
le pitch je veux bien sûr c'est un des
textes les plus poétiques de la
sélection parce que c'est un roman assez
atypique il est en vers libres j'évalue
que c'était d'antoine nouveaux auteurs
soient là ah oui pardon d'antoine motors
lui c'est l'histoire c'est l'histoire se
déroule en syrie
il s'agit d'un vieux poète qui s'appelle
mahmoud
et c'est quelqu'un qui plonge dans un
lac c'est le lac
construit dans les années 70
donc dans la vallée de l'euphrate et
cela qu'il a englouti la ville d'enfance
de mahmoud donc ils passent la fin de sa
vie à être soit sur la barque à les
souvenirs luynes remonte à la tête ou
soit il plonge carrément dans ses
souvenirs en plongeant dans le lac c'est
quelque chose de c'est un livre à mon
très poétique et en même temps quand il
n'est pas dans le lac ou sur le lac il y
as tout là toute la guerre qui se passe
autour de lui notamment en 2017 quand
des ch a repris
ce barrage donc c'est un relais enfin il
ya beaucoup de poésie mais pour parler
de beaucoup de douleur et de souffrance
et pourquoi en vers libres parce que
ensuite voilà le la barque qui est comme
ça dans l'eau
c'est des verts livres qui sont assez
week assez pour montrer le chaos qui
règne en syrie donc c'est vraiment un
livre très très pognon travail sur la
langue des femmes est en furie qui en
m'insultant si on peut voir mais c'est
c'est presque de la poésie départ
arrivée dans la forme
la poésie
antoine moteur céder quoi il est belge
oui un sens
c'était ces missionnaires dit non c'est
les éditions verdier oui
non c'est très original quoi
oui c'est tout à fait originale et je ne
connaissais absolument pas moteur se
donne envie de venir
antoine wauters mahmoud où la montée des
eaux aux éditions verdier on va
continuer je pars lundi je crois qu'il
vous a beaucoup de toucher tous les deux
qu'ils s'appellent rien ne t'appartient
essai d'un auteur que vous aimez
beaucoup énormément qu'ils natacha
mougel gallimard gallimard
une écriture magnifique je trouve dans
tous ses romans
énormément énormément d'attachement pour
cet écrivain essaie s'appelle donc rien
ne t'appartient
chez gallimard alors qui est que j'ai
goûts tous les deux vous avez été assez
envoûté parce que oui
alors d'abord on suit l'histoire de tara
c'est une jeune femme qui au début a
perdu son mari et la première
la première scène se passe chez elle on
ne sait pas exactement dans quel pays
elle dans lequel pays ça se passe mais
ans et de son mari s'appelle et même
s'appeler emmanuel elle voit son beau
fils vient la voir et ensuite on la suit
tout le long on sorte de flash back qui
retrace sa vie dans un pays qui n'est
pas nommé mais en faisant quelques
recherches on se rend compte que c'est
le sri lanka
et c'est le et ça relate donc c'est sa
vie avant le tsunami je ne sais plus
quelle année vide et 2004 oui voilà de
2004 et c'est un livre qui est vraiment
très très touchant qui parle de
oui vraiment extrêmement touchants
pourquoi rien ne t'appartient c'est une
phrase qui est dit qui est dit dans le
livre un des personnages au personnage
principal quand elle arrive dans un
orphelinat où la directrice de
l'orphelinat midi ici rien ne
t'appartient et avant de lui prendre
toutes les affaires qu'elle avait
qu'elle avait et de lui donner les
affaires oui très très violent mais en
attendant merci à 13 sombre sans qu'il y
ait à partir sauf sa vie justement mais
tout ce livre montre combien cette cette
femme qui s'appelle taratata rawicz
ailleurs on ne sait pas trop elle a les
deux prénoms
rien ne lui appartient sauf sa vie elle
avait voulu vivre elle veut vivre à tout
prix comme elle l'entend
alors j'imagine qu'on retrouve j'étais
encore l'uss celui-là cette écriture
comme ça ou en permanence à la recherche
du mot juste chez natacha appanah appuyé
une certaine ce
voile a l'impression qu'elle à chaque
fois dans son écriture que quand les
mots sont posés ou les pauses mais à
condition de ne pas heurter l'autre il
ya ce rapport à autrui extrêmement
délicat et le temps violent il ya un
alliage comme ça de violence chez eux et
de délicatesse dans son écriture qui
fait que cette écriture est très belle
mais qu'est-ce qu'on le retrouvera dans
celui là comme dans les neiges au faux
parce que le faux est très traumatisant
il ya beaucoup de violence
on sait l'histoire de comment pas pour
rappeler qu'on appelle trop souvent une
fille gachet et sur cette histoire
extrêmement traumatisantes il y a
justement le là toute la plume de
natacha appanah qui parce qu'elle est
sobre et qu'elle est elle il ya une
grande poésie qui permet voilà de deux
lignes toute cette violence avec on peut
lire on peut lire ce livre voilà encore
en somme il à la violence est rendu
possible grâce à la cette écriture
extrêmement poétique et vous a marqué ah
oui
j'ai hâte de lire à la rescousse et va
le roulement de tambour battant
est ce que va donner le le gagnant du
roman du prêt étudiant 2021 et ne
t'arrête pas se couvrir de mathieu
parent voilà
alors là on est entre et c'est
intéressant parce que vous les aurez
tandis que devait rencontrer mathieu
blin on est entre l'enquêté le roman
parce qu'il ya une part de vrai dans ce
livre mais si oui
il était rencontré son héros en prison
enfin sarah c'est ça c'est en alors
alors à côté c'est fonder sur les
témoignages de toumani coulibaly n'ont
qu'un athlète français et de ses proches
également et ça retrace ça retrace sa
vie
et les crimes qu'il a commis puisqu'il a
combiné à plusieurs reprises dévoile des
vols par effraction de désir
il est utilisé par
les juristes ah oui pardon
il était en prison oui dans tous les cas
il a aidé a été en prison je crois qu'il
en est ressorti maintenant après bon et
ce qui est intéressant aussi c'est qu'on
voit également
la démarche
oui c'est ça exactement mais ce qu'il
commence le livre vraiment lorsqu'il va
le rencontrer en fait et il se met en
scène comme un personnage à part entière
et on le et voilà donc c'est le récit
alors
justement alors je dis bon il était
rencontré un type est en prison et les
crises de son histoire où elle roman
justement j'en avais parlé de ça et la
frontière
de la frottée entre le rebond l'enquète
c'est très compliqué parce que
il s'agit d'un livre il s'agit plus d'un
article de journal
donc il ya forcément un petit peu cia
récit il ya forcément un petit peu de
fictions made à nos côtés mathieu palun
il est journaliste et il veut vraiment
voilà rapporter les faits tels qu'ils
sont donc l'activité on attend
c'est comment on fait avec ça c'est
quelque chose dont on a parlé aussi avec
lui et oui en classe maintenant parce
que
l'objectivité qu'on attend d'un
journaliste n'est pas vraiment on la
retrouve pas vraiment dans ce livre
justement puisque dès le début il se
compare aux il se compare à la folie de
la lire et à toutes ils ont grandi à peu
près dans la même dans la même zone
géographique ils ont le même âge et
s'ils ont les mêmes références
culturelles et c c'est assez spécifique
enfin l'objectivité on la retrouve pas
vraiment mais en même temps on peut la
retrouver un peu dense dans la démarche
qu'il a dans la démarche du liffe us et
vu que c'est un livre avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de détails vraiment une très
très grande attention aux détails et
et tout du moins c'est ce qui nous a dit
quand on l'a rencontré pour lui il pense
qu'on lui a dit la vérité et il a écrit
pour lui ce qui était vrai truzion
cia petites références que l'on veut
passer c'est l'adversaire de carhaix
vous connaissez noir est balisé le ccri
20 francs son nom c'était sûr sur une
affaire c'est la confrontation justement
d'un écrivain avec une affaire
judiciaire étonnante qui est l affaire
roman la sphère roman roman est un type
qui avait fait croire à toute sa famille
pendant des années qu'il était médecin
il ne l'était pas il avait raté sa
troisième année de médecine et le jour
il était plus ou moins acculé au bout de
de 15 à 20 ans les enfants et cédera il
a tué ses parents sa famille sa femme
ses enfants et ses et carrère a été
confronté à 7,7 cette affaire comme ça
il l'a pas été visités roman en prison
mais c'est vrai que c'était un peu la
même chose c'est à dire que c'est qu'est
ce qu'il y avait de lui dans cette
bourse true grit et ou éthique ce qui
peut avoir de peindre dans
banco liboli enfin il se demanda aussi
quoi un peu non
oui bien sûr parce qu'ils viennent du
même quartier et mathieu palun voilà son
livre il pose la question de pourquoi
certains réussissent pourquoi d'autres
ne réussisse ne me suis pas
des termes ou pain je ne sais pas
finalement peut-être en arrière fond je
pense que marié en fond il ya surtout
cette question par rapport au syndrome
du banc du banlieusard est ce que là on
est
sandrine est ce qu'une espèce de
fatalité et on existe y ait ce qui est
destiné ce qu'on est condamné à avoir un
comportement tel ou tel comportement
selon l'endroit où on est loin des
occasions qu'on a eues mais ce cas pas
justement la liberté qui fait que la
liberté où cette intelligence key to
many coulibaly a parce que voilà lui il
sait quand il est en prison ne se dit
pas bon ben c'est ici ma place non il
c'est quelqu'un qui est très intelligent
fin du mois razer à concevoir et qui
s'en sort et qui était à la tête
génial en finale c'est 5,5 que ça comme
un cadeau de noël sans cadeaux de noël
qu'on veut faire on rappelle que le prix
donc c'est ne t'arrête pas de courir de
de mathieu palun et c'est aux éditions
de l'iconoclaste un mot peut-être
d'envoi dans les romans que vous lisez
qu'est ce qui vous impressionne le plus
qu'est ce qui vous intéresse le plus
c'est l'histoire qu'on vous raconte
c'est le style avec lequel s'est raconté
ses les deux peut-être pas séparer le
fond et la forme ça dépend aussi des sa
dépendance et des lectures je pense que
c'est une lecture plus pour pour
l'université on a tendance à plus 100 je
sais que personnellement j'ai tendance à
regarder un peu plus le slv le style ici
c'est des lectures vraiment dire si
c'est des lectures pour mme en général
plus l'histoire qui nous portent plutôt
que
on a des étudiants qui aiment lire moi
ça me fait plaisir parce que c'est pas
le cas de tous les étudiants souvent nos
étudiants choisissent des spécialités
par exemple au droit la médecine puis
ils sont ensuite de très très bons
techniciens et se passionne pour la
discipline qu'il embrasse mais oubliant
parfois et bien tous ces romans qui font
la vie et donc c'est formidable à deux
boxeurs qui lit un message d'abord
inquiet mais c'est formidable et bien de
voir ben bravo vous en faites votre
médecin bravo bravo pour vous au choix
bravo pour votre votre master qui se
continue à partir de janvier
pour les examens vous venez ici quand
vous voulez me chronique et délivre
d'accord avec plaisir soucis donc
caroline sers des raidillons le marchand
merci infiniment merci merci à 10 pour
cent mille merci à vous merci et à très
bientôt pour une nouvelle grille de
lecture